hey this is presh talwalkar
what is the value of the following
fraction
the fraction is in the shape of a
triangle
it has 10 rows the very bottom row is
equal to 1 and every row above it is one
more than the previous row
that's part one of the question
part two
consider this type of fraction where we
have an even number of rows
what will the fraction approximately be
equal to
if we let the number of rows go to
infinity
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's get started by evaluating one plus
one all over one
this is equal to two and we'll call this
a two
now let's consider the fraction with
four rows
this is equal to four divided by three
divided by a two this is equal to 4
times 2
because a2 is equal to 2
all over 3.
notice we have a kind of pattern
4 times 2
is 4 factorial except we've skipped
every other number
and we have 3 times 1 which is 3
factorial except we skip every other
number
this is written in shorthand as 4 double
factorial and 3 double factorial
so a4 is equal to 4 double factorial
divided by 3 double factorial
what about a6
this is equal to 6 divided by 5 over a4
a4 is equal to 4 double factorial
divided by 3 double factorial
substituting in
we get 6 times 4 times two
all over
five times three
so this is equal to six double factorial
over five double factorial and that's
equal to a6
so if we continue this pattern we'll see
that a2k
is equal to 2k double factorial all over
2k minus 1 double factorial
so we want to evaluate a 10 which is
equal to 10 double factorial divided by
9 double factorial
with careful calculation this is equal
to 256
divided by 63
which is approximately equal to 4.06
but we have a fun surprise in this
problem
the ratio
2k double factorial divided by 2k minus
1 double factorial
asymptotically
is equal
to the square root of pi times k
so let's imagine we wanted to take this
fraction and evaluate
a of 1000
this is equal to 1000 double factorial
divided by
999 double factorial
this will be very difficult to compute
but we can use the asymptotic
approximation to see this will
approximately be equal to the square
root of 500 pi
which is approximately equal to 39.633
if we put the double factorials in
something like wolfram alpha we'll get
the exact value is approximately equal
to 39.643
so we can see the asymptotic
approximation is pretty good and we
don't have to calculate these very
complicated double factorials
but this is a very fun surprise that we
were just calculating fractions and pi
came out of nowhere
wow
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you